dans le monde entier hier pendant
plusieurs heures le trafic sur internet
s'est ralentie ou paralyser un virus
serait à l'origine de cette attaque
d'envergure que nous explique sophie
rodier et joseph beuys tic un grain de
sable dans les rouages d'internet etc le
réseau mondial qui tremble hier un
nouveau virus appelé saphir s'est
propagée en quelques heures de serveurs
en serveurs à travers le monde
bouleversant le fonctionnement de
dizaines d'entreprises des informations
nous parviennent de corée d'allemagne de
grande bretagne des états unis canada
jusqu'à maintenant nous estimons que 150
à 200 mille machines ont été infectées
par le virus
le coupable c'est l'auteur de ce petit
programme qui est su exploiter une
faille d'un logiciel de microsoft selon
ce spécialiste
le pirate a sans doute été dépassé par
sa création
cette démarche est grave parce qu'elle
démontre la fragilité du système
c'est ce que l'on démonte nous ici
régulièrement et donc la capacité qui
aurait pour des terroristes éventuelle
de d'utiliser ces attaques comme une
arme
ce soir le béa et recherche activement
le pirate l'attaquent elle a été
maîtrisé mais certains experts
remarquent que cette panne informatique
importante intervient à un moment où les
grands de ce monde sont réunis à davos
et dans un contexte international
troublé il n'est pas interdit d'y voir
un lien